you have to slow down and slowing down
means you have to reflect and it means
that you have to listen and listen and
listen some more when you start to truly
listen what happens is that you begin to
again self reflect and that isn't
necessarily the most comfortable thing
over the last 25 years in working in
professional service firms over and over
again I would find myself talking with
conversing with individuals who in many
respects never wanted to slow down
incredibly smart a little bit defensive
when you gave them feedback felt in many
respects that they were really good at
everything that they did without ever
asking actually some tough questions
about whether they really were competent
or not in things like management who
after a while seemed to spend more time
managing their image than actually
worrying about our am I really improving
or am I trying new things and it seemed
like that they were becoming more and
more frightened about about some very
very basic things while their lives
seemed to be working and they seemed to
be progressing and they seemed to be
achieving and accomplishing if for some
reason you tell them that they're
falling down in a particular area what
happens is they begin to see themselves
as an absolute failure as opposed to
saying well you know I'm overwhelmed I
have a lot of things that I need to
balance anything that gets in the way of
them not accomplishing at the end of the
day starts to feel like a distraction
often relationships begin to suffer with
these individuals they find themselves
rather than listening with their
children they find themselves asking for
accountability they find themselves
giving directions and offering advice
they find themselves asking questions
like what did you do today have you done
have you applied for college I mean
you're seven years old we aren't you
applying for college how white your room
dirty and so they're still in that role
of accomplish check things off when you
start having those kinds of feelings of
you know what I may be inadequate in
these other dimensions what you do is
you find yourself going faster and
faster